to the country of georgia where
protesters have been calling for the
prime minister to resign
over the death of a journalist alexander
lascarava
worked for an independent television
news channel
he was found dead at his home on sunday
after he was badly beaten by a far-right
activist
during a protest against an lgbtq pride
march in the capital tbilisi
attacked for doing his job now found
dead
cameraman alexander lashkarava was
beaten by right-wing mobs
while covering an anti-lgbtq riot
the exact circumstances of his death are
still unclear
thousands have taken to the streets in
solidarity with the journalists
angry protesters accused the government
of
enabling the violence we hold the
government directly responsible for
failing to provide security for the
journalists and therefore we believe
that resignation of the prime minister
and the government
is the only response that will be
satisfactory to the georgian society in
these circumstances
it's a very clear and precise message
the government that has organized
pogroms by their
radical groups specifically targeted to
the
to towards journalists and has
multiple people who are damaged and now
one
one dead has to resign
last week rioters attacked the lgbtq
campaign offices in georgia's capital
tibilisi
lashkarava was there and filmed the
attackers
around 50 journalists were injured
lashkarava's death has further inflamed
tensions
and more demonstrations are expected
and just moments ago we had the
opportunity to catch up with zura
abbas he'd say he is a georgian writer
and lgbtq activist
and we began our conversation by asking
him if he feels that the georgian
government
is complicit in what happened to mr
lashkarava
they kind of want us to lose many focus
and switch to another direction where
there is only collapse and clash between
georgian people
this is the only way for government to
make us blind and hide how
georgian people struggle with love
economy with injustice
they want to make us blind for not to
see corruption we have in our country
and this is so sad that they are
choosing minority and lgbt people to
hide their weakness
so what's it like can you describe for
our international viewers you're also a
writer yourself
what's it like being a member of the
media or a writer
in uh georgia can you without fear for
life
conduct your uh your job
yeah like those past few days was super
hard for everyone especially
people of lgbtqi community me for
example i'm staying at home most of the
time
going out without friends or without any
people is not safe anymore if you look
like different or like if you're wearing
some like earrings or like
i don't know they would find any reason
to like beat you in the streets
we all scared and we all started to
think about leaving our country
especially like uh journalists like
writers and
many other people from like uh art or
like media
because we don't see any future for
minority in georgia but this is not
this is hard because one of the main
statements from people from far right
movement
for lesbian gay bee trans plus community
is to leave georgia for good or hide in
a closet
zura georgian writer and lgbtq
activist sir thank you so much for
joining us and sharing your views with
us
we appreciate it thank you
you